Speaker 1: . At midnight last night. Failed former
president. Twice impeached and once arrested,
Donald Trump seemed to have a textual panic attack
on troth essential over what appears to be at this
time an inevitable forthcoming indictment and
arrest federally. Federally. These are the all
capital letters posts of a panicked madman who
is scared and maybe realizing that his time is
running out. Trump posting at midnight last night,
quote, shocking. One of the top prosecutors at
the Department of Justice was reportedly so
obsessed with getting Trump that he tried to
bribe and intimidate a lawyer representing someone
being targeted and harassed to falsely accuse
and fabricate a story about President Donald J.
Trump, a crime that doesn't exist. This criminal
and salacious act from within the DOJ has brought
criminal and salacious. It has brought shame and
embarrassment to this once great and respected
institution. I struggle so badly to read these
Trump rants. Because of this, there is now extreme
turmoil inside the DOJ. Unclear that that's true.
Trump continuing on post to and labeling it. Page
two A top overzealous and dishonest DOJ prosecutor
offered a witnesses lawyer an important judgeship
in the Biden administration if his client flips on
President Trump, who has done nothing wrong.
The highly respected lawyer was incensed and
disgusted at the corrupt. And illegal offer.
The fake case against me must be immediately
dropped and the inspector general should launch an
investigation into this and the many other all too
obvious wrongdoings and crimes taking place at the
DOJ and FBI. It's very difficult to find anything
that is true here. We do not have any evidence
of alleged crimes committed by the DOJ and FBI.
We have no evidence at this time that there is
overzealous prosecution of Donald Trump. In fact,
the truth is the opposite. The concern has
been and the rumblings have pointed to,
even with evidence against Trump of Trump
criminality. It doesn't seem clear that
there's a willingness by the Department of Justice
to actually indict a former president. We now are
starting to believe that that's not true and that
the DOJ is going to go forward and indict Trump.
But there is essentially nothing real here. But
you have to understand that this is the court of
public opinion and the maggot, the maggots or
the maggot donations or whatever they're being
called at this point in time. They accept this
stuff like it's being spoon fed to them. They
they uncritically accept it, period. End of story.
And so much of this could be working to activate
voters either for the Republican primary or
the eventual general election in November of
24. There are all sorts of other reasons why
Trump would be doing this, including that the
guy is just panicking and scared because he's
already been indicted and arrested once. And
it could happen three more times. We're going
to follow it all very closely by the time this
show is out. We may already know more or we
may not until tomorrow or maybe next week.